we're surrounded by some powerful ideas
about the sort of things that will make
us happy we tend to think that really to
deliver satisfaction the pleasures we
should aim for need to be rare we've
inherited a romantic suspicion of the
ordinary which is taken to be mediocre
dull and uninspiring and work with a
corresponding assumption that things
that are unique hard-to-find exotic or
unfamiliar and naturally fitted to
delight us more then we want things to
be expensive
we like economic endorsement if
something is cheap or free it's a little
harder to appreciate the pineapple for
instance dropped off a lot of people's
wishlist of fruit when its price fell
from exorbitant they used to cost the
equivalent of hundreds of pounds to
unremarkable caviar continues to sound
somehow more interesting than chicken
eggs then we want things to be famous in
a fascinating experiment a celebrated
violinist once donned scruffy clothes
and bust at a street corner and was
largely ignored though people would
flock to the world's greatest concert
halls to hear just the same man play
just the same pieces lastly we want
things to be large-scale we mostly
focused on big schemes that we hope will
deliver big kinds of enjoyment marriage
career travel getting a new house these
approaches aren't entirely wrong but
unwittingly
they collectively exhibit a vicious and
unhelpful bias against the cheap the
easily available the ordinary the
familiar and the small scale as a result
if someone says they've been on a trip
to Belize by private jet we
automatically assume they had a better
time than someone who went to the local
park by bike we imagine that visiting
the Uffizi gallery in Florence is always
going to be nicer than reading a
paperback novel in the back garden a
restaurant dinner at which Lobster
Thermidor is served sounds a good deal
more impressive than a supper of a
cheese sandwich at home it feels more
normal that the highlight of a weekend
should be a hand gliding lesson rather
than a few minutes spent looking at the
cloudy sky it feels odd to suggest that
a modest farce of lily of the valley the
cheapest bloom that many florists might
yield more sad
function that of Van Gogh original and
yet the paradoxical and cheering aspect
of pleasure is how weird and promiscuous
it can prove to be it doesn't neatly
collect in the most expensive boutiques
it can refuse to stick with us on fancy
holidays it's remarkably vulnerable to
emotional trouble sulks and casual bad
moods a fights that began with a small
disagreement about how to pronounce a
word can end up destroying every benefit
of a five-star resort a pleasure may
look very minor eating a fig having a
bath whispering in bed in the dark
talking to a grandparent or scanning
through old photos of when you were a
child and yet these pleasures can be
anything but small if properly grasped
and elaborated upon these sort of
activities may be among the most moving
and satisfying we can have appreciating
what is to hand isn't a slacker solution
it isn't an attack on ambition but
there's no point in chasing the future
until and unless we are better at being
more attuned to the modest moments and
things that are presently already
available to us more fundamentally the
smallness of small pleasures isn't
really an assessment of how much they
have to offer us it's a reflection of
how many good things the world unfairly
neglects a small pleasure is a great
pleasure in waiting it's a great
pleasure which is not yet received the
collective acknowledgement it is due
appreciating small pleasures means
trusting our own responses a little more
we can't wait for everything that's
lovely and charming to be approved by
others before we allow ourselves to be
enchanted we need to follow the muted
signals of our own brains and allow that
we are on to something important even
though others may not yet be in
agreement
you